runners to your marks
while salary doesn't cover the mortgage
you're gonna have to start pulling your
weight around here Eli's money I need
you to run it to him hey Jacobs granting
all the way from the docks same clip
yeah so about five minute mile
that's your schoolbag go find your
brother I wouldn't send me around to see
a guy like me Coleman needs to catch
Jack Perry is pretty legendary yeah so
you could get a scholarship you think a
five-minute Mouse fast how fast to get a
scholarship to UC Berkeley you know the
chance I'll do whatever you say
get in the water but get in the water
I've been training with Coleman you're
running go
the miles your race you run it fast
enough even go anywhere you want
why am i doing all the work well wax on
wax off I need you to come with me
would you think this is over you're in
this now
he's a really good kid if he keeps
running he'd get away from all that
we're just gonna give up
well things not just physical it's in
your head that face that's fear
I got it don't you
why are you doing this because he's fast
if you do face that big and that's just
the beginning